look that we're in that that afterglow
of the draft where everybody had a great
draft everybody's a playoff contender
everybody's gonna be 14 and - except for
the Giants everybody everybody has
reason to to think about what they
otherwise we'll be doing in late January
early February and maybe they'll be in
Miami because their team's gonna be in
the Superbowl so this is part of the
look and this is natural yeah but it's
also part of the the manufacturing and
selling of hope even though at the end
of the day it's probably gonna be the
Patriots again at least for a while
other teams can think hey maybe there's
a way it'll be us and one of the
Patriots biggest rivals right the
rivalries back on that's what chris
ballard said last year when josh
mcdaniels stiff-armed the cult's and
stayed with the patriots as the
offensive coordinator instead of
becoming the head coach in indianapolis
the cult's ended up being much better
than we thought they would be last year
due in large part to Andrew Luck being
healthy and there's every reason to
believe Chris that the Colts are going
to be and it's quietly right we're
caught up on the Chiefs and the Browns
and the Patriots there's reason to
believe the Colts are gonna be right
there with them when it's all said and
done yeah I mean yes I mean you said it
Andrew Luck I mean he was better than we
thought he was gonna be the shoulder you
know reacted better than we were
expecting Frank Reich we were all going
to I mean can he really be a head coach
he was kind of a last minute sign there
you know because josh mcdaniels backed
away or backed off Frank Reich was
phenomenal not only an attitude but game
plan you know exposing team's defensive
schemes in a weekly basis that was
amazing and then you know going back to
Chris Ballard hey the reason they're
good is because of Chris Ballard I mean
he's just there's no doubt about it that
Chris Ballard is one of the best GM's in
football he is in that conversation
whether you want to say he's one three
whatever it may be but he is towards the
top when you can draft guys like Darius
Leonard in the second round and other
guys that mid-round drop picks who
contributed the team that's where a team
can jump from being average to playoff
fringe and then this draft getting three
picks in the second round to one defense
that are of course gonna help their team
but I look at that third pick in the
second
Parris Campbell the most explosive
receiver in the draft falling all the
way down to the to the end of the second
round to go to an offense that was
pretty damn loaded to begin with maybe
could have used another weapon but good
tight end play got a stable of three
running backs with naheem Hinds Wilkins
and Marlon Mac and then you talk about T
Y Hills and Gavin dump Devin Funchess in
the end the off season guys like Chester
Rodgers and now you got a Paris Campbell
guy Mike who I kind of compared to like
a Percy Harvin coming out of college I
mean he's a guy that can catch a little
short pass and run 80 yards by everybody
for a touchdown he can catch a little
speed sweep or a reverse and turn the
corner and and take it 80 yards to the
house so this offense has a little bit
of everything and they are going to be
scary yeah and you know you mentioned
Chris Ballard is one of the top teams in
the NFL and I think he is humble enough
and self-aware enough that he would say
you can't put him in that conversation
until he has a Pelt on the wall or a
pellet on the horse as you would say yes
and and and and he's and I think he'd be
fine with that because why do you want
to exhale before you're at the top of
the mountain and you're not at the top
of the mountain until you win a Super
Bowl and you know he's got an owner who
keeps promising Super Bowls and and has
set the standard at three in a row not
not not just get one but but three
consecutively that's the way that you
are judged is one of the best teams of
all time and look I
the Colts got a long way to go to get
one but they're moving in the right
direction remember when ballard was with
us last year at the league meetings we
asked him how long it would take to
really turn this thing around and he
said it's gonna take two drafts
well one draft is all it took yeah I'm
gonna get to all pros every draft you're
gonna have a dominant team sooner rather
than later
ya know you're exactly right and that's
the beauty of Ballard as he does seem to
find you know the correct value and
matching it up with you know where the
value on his board is as far as how good
these football players he doesn't
overdraft he has complete confidence in
his ability to evaluate players to go oh
okay yeah I'll I'll pass up this end to
the first-round pick there's nobody
there that really strikes a need for our
team or has a high value we feel like we
can trade down and accumulate more picks
and I can find a guy may be just as good
as the guy that's gonna be drafted at
the end of the first round or the value
might just be minutely different to
where he feels good about it taking it
30 spots later whatever it is but that's
the beauty of a good football team is
being able to find guys like that on a
consistent basis Ballard's awesome that
way and they've done a good job in free
agency to strengthening their football
team to to where you look at the Colts
and you look at the AFC South Mike and I
just go damn is that division good I
mean the Texans aren't going anywhere I
would be shocked if Jacksonville's not
better with Nick Foles and some of the
things they've done and then you add the
Colts who are already good and got
better this offseason and yes the
Tennessee Titans I just go who gets out
of that division right now because it's
pretty damn stacked he may be one of
those years where we see the division
champion plus two wild cards coming from
that division yeah we've seen that
multiple times in recent years Chris
Ballard has done such a good job
compiling talent for the Indianapolis
Colts that now people involved with
turning that talent into positive
results praising what they have Frank
Reich and T Y Hilton both see big things
coming from the Colts offense here they
are it's funny I've said this to you
guys before but as a coach you always
feel you you so much love the guys you
work with that you you I always think
hey we don't need anybody else we
already got the best guys in the world
playing for us and then all of a sudden
now you're throwing you're giving us
more this this isn't fair it's not going
to be fair and then you get a guy that
runs for 3-1 and you just say it's going
to be fun to see these guys work
together
what is office is gonna be scared you
know the office of line it starts with
them and they're doing tremendous job up
front give me Andrew time get my
quarterbacks time and then the running
bags make you go and tidy in the
receiver you just had to have a fun look
this really can be a great great offense
and it's all because Andrew Luck is back
to who he was and a year ago we didn't
know he was gonna be the guy that he was
it really is remarkable and and and my
position was I'm not gonna believe it
until I see it because throughout the
2017 season Chris I felt like at some
level
the cults were lying to us whether it
was intentional or unintentional I felt
like they were deliberately overstating
Andrew Luck's health his prospects his
ability to play and that ended up being
a lost season and remember last year it
was in June he was not throwing a
full-sized NFL family so there was
reason to be concerned and it's
remarkable what he's done to turn his
career around and get back to being one
of the best quarterbacks in the NFL and
as long as you have him playing at that
level this Colts team needs to be taken
seriously yeah they do they're legit
because you know as we've seen too many
times in Andrew Luck's career with
they're within striking distance in the
fourth quarter watch out my money's on
Andrew Luck in those situations he
delivers more times than not and yeah
there's a lot of things to like hey the
biggest thing and T why Hilton said it
there and you know the reason Andrew
Luck got to continue to get better as
the year went on his damn Jim Irsay
I mean come on he built the ball Mike
it's the best of all we never seed Mike
it's the greatest ball money can buy the
big blue wall I had to say I don't know
I'm not familiar with any of them oh
great well the walls are popular in
conversation and rock you've been under
I know those slats built slag they got
five strong slats there I know that in
Indianapolis they're secured we lose
sight of that though yeah you know and
even at a time where we recognize that
quarterback is the most important aspect
of a team and the second-most important
is getting to the quarterback from the
defensive side we continue to gloss over
and it's the way it's always been with
football and I don't know why that is
but those five guys tackle to tackle who
are responsible for opening running
lanes responsible for keeping the
quarterback upright and doing all sorts
of complicated movements together in
certain types of offenses they just get
taken for granted and they only get
noticed when they stink
when they're good it's someone else who
gets the praise but we really need to
appreciate what they've put together the
Quentin Nelson pick last year was
masterful because not only does he come
in with a high degree of ability
he sets the tone for the other guys and
you need that guy who becomes the alpha
dog among the offensive linemen and if
you can keep those guys healthy all year
long and it's the same combination it's
so much easier to know what to do when
to do it how to move in unison instead
of breaking in some new guy that doesn't
know what the hell he's doing and what
we need to we need to come up with a
better way to properly praise these guys
that's my challenge to you okay
something for this season whether it's a
weekly award well you know it whether
it's for an entire offensive line
whether it's for one offensive lineman
something to really show the connection
between what they do every play right
and what the guys who rack up the
fantasy football stats you know you've
come up with your f up to play stat
right for the defensive player yeah
that's the challenge I need something
from you on the offensive side of the
ball that lets us shine a brighter light
on the importance and value of an
offensive line I will work on that
because I think that's a very valid
point and you know - what you're saying
- you look at a lot of the top offenses
in football the top teams in football
one thing they had it was good offensive
lines I mean that's just really there's
no other way to to really talk about it
you know their ability to dominate up
front run the ball when need be pass
protect the quarterback and a lineman
yes they are you you hit on so many good
points they got to work in unison it's
got to be a unit together there's got to
be a lot of communication at the line of
scrimmage and how to block certain plays
how to pick up blitzes oh wait the
quarterbacks checking we got to get into
this play and then we got a we got a you
know now change our blocking scheme and
get to this all of that goes along let
alone when you have five guys that are
on the field all together it gives the
offensive call play caller and the
offensive game plan designer the
confidence to put more and more on the
offensive line to go ooh this is
complicated but damn these five have
been together for a while and there's
great communication so I can put a
little more on their plate and that's
when offenses can start to break you
know molds and start doing special
things and that's really what they do
they have the best offensive line in
football you said it Quintin Nelson's a
great driving force behind that an O
linemen are just so conservative by
nature they're not usually boisterous or
loud that you're exactly right they
don't get the attention they does
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports